started by tatum draggage clears it out
butler downhill on tatum into traffic
got it
and one clutch time dade county
jimmy butler delivering
yet again the miami heat in the paint
and jimmy butler again has taken 68
percent of his shots
from right in that area he is relentless
gets the angle and the step on tatum
takes the contact and scores it
48-26 the advantage in the paint and the
heat bench is like yes sir
that's our closer doris
i swear tatum bounced off him twice on
the same drive
[Applause]
the lead is two and brad stevens
calls timeout meanwhile over on espn
news game seven denver and clippers
underway tied at six but plenty of time
walker back in for offense joined by
tatum crowder out of bio iguodala in the
ball game for miami defensively
butler and derek jones back in
defensively
[Music]
tatum out front
clock at seven working against butler
got downhill couldn't punch it
bam says get it out of here out of bio
sky high with the block and rejection
that's why he's nba all defensive team
bam out of bio went airborne with jason
tatum
and add a bio one
[Applause]
wow a meeting at the summit doris
that is a ridiculous defensive play
jason tatum is clearly by everybody else
high above the rim looks like it's going
to be an easy dunk and
bam says not in my house
[Applause]
this is the free throw but 17 points
six rebounds nine assists in a key block
no timeouts here for boston
no timeouts and it's still just a one
possession game because he missed that
free throw
make or miss this is a one possession
game but you've got to get it
to the three-point line the 2.5 if he
makes it
knocks down the second the lead is three
boston needs a three do they foul or not
we'll see if they do it on the catch not
tatum makes the catch
got it off in time online but no good
and the heat win game one in